uh so i want to write that story i want
to write a big story that people
uh that young people who look up to and
say i want to be that person one day
[Music]
raza brahmo thank you for being on my
show how are you thank you for having me
oh as well how are you
everything is great it's so late in tel
aviv right now thank you for being here
at this hour
i'm really excited for for this talk and
to chat with you and to learn about
you know your journey both as an
entrepreneur as a vp rnd transitioning
to
product from vpr d and talking about
everything from
helping run the company from bootstrap
to
moving between different customers
around the world and i can't wait to
learn as much as i can over those 20
minutes
but raz i'd like to start off tell me a
little bit about your journey how did
you get started
how did you end up vpr d at ever
compliant
so long journey indeed uh but only
that's only the beginning
um so uh i've been a technology uh
technologist from a young age um ever
since i could
pick up a keyboard and start typing
basically i started developing code
um how early was that would you say
seventh grade i think my dad pushed
who's also a developer
i still by the way today um pushed a c
plus plus book to my lap and said
start reading as i started reading um
so basically at 12 you while everyone
while a lot of people were reading harry
potter 12 you were reading a book on c
plus plus
something like that okay good just
clarifying for everybody yeah
um then throughout high school and my
bachelor's degree
i think science and then i joined the
army to 800 units
on the technology center
uh where i did uh service um
also did some uh training uh
i uh guided the course that i uh that i
did oh really
the junior yeah junior soldier that was
a lot of fun
and after five years i uh um i got
released and um then i started uh
freelancing actually i wanted to taste a
little bit of everything
uh so did everything from uh software to
chip designs
to uh mobile apps for uh
i helped help a lot of people making
their dreams come true
and then i decided that i want to follow
around how long
were you how long did you do freelancing
for about
three years um so when we started the
ever compliance uh my company
um i uh i still we were bootstrapped so
i still did a little bit of financing at
first
uh but then we transitioned to full time
once uh we saw it hit off
now i do want to do to delay on on this
comment that you made
you said something about helping others
make their dreams come true
right it's with freelancing elaborate a
little bit about that because it's an
interesting way of phrasing what
what you were doing as a freelancer and
then you chose to do it for three years
to
perhaps gain perspective but what does
that mean to you that you were helping
others
achieve their achieve their dreams or
making them come true
um so as as i was working
finding clients is less of a problem you
when you have
the community that we have in the
israeli
military so i worked with a lot of
entrepreneurs that had
different challenges in different areas
uh where they had the vision they had
the idea that the great concept of how
they want to see
how they want to see their idea come
true and uh they need some guidance in
the technology area so just to someone
just can
tie it all together and show them how we
show them that forward and and that was
that was a great pleasure for me to work
with them on these areas and
really uh really to see the spark in
their eyes when they see the first uh
the finished product and the work that
we can do
so just to clarify you were coming to
the you would come in
and help these you know entrepreneurs
founders etc
or other technology teams and you would
come and help them with your
skill sets come in help them with the
product bring it to fruition bring their
vision
on on the computer and then you and then
they would enjoy this product
and then something within you said okay
i want to do this myself i want to
create my own company
okay so we're there now tell me a little
bit about ever compliant
uh so we started um in the garage
um two quarters and the ceo uh
we're just looking for looking for the
following for customers uh we actually
pivoted a few times before we start
current
idea uh we started the bootstrap
completely so we're gonna fund ourselves
until uh and so we saw the idea really
head off and uh um
i think that uh the first um first major
milestone was that around the
funding which we raised from uh carmel
ventures uh today
and that happened after uh we landed our
first to your
client nice i got that yeah so
uh we we've been working with them on
the product for a few uh
for about a year and as we raised their
own day um
we saw that their problem is really an
international problem global problem
and um they had a problem with
merchants passing illegal activity
through them without them knowing so
they were working with um
with a company they thought was selling
shoes out of disney golf
and turns out that they have been hiding
illegal illegal activity i won't mention
the specifics because
yeah okay 13 right
um but uh yeah so we developed
technology to help them
to help them see that from game
visibility into those areas
mainly in the e-commerce space and uh we
saw that this problem was
uh was global so we went to uh we took
our
our luggage and went to mastercard and
said uh hi
we noticed a problem and can we help you
uh
uh solve it they said you arrived at the
right time this is a problem we know
we've known about it and we've been
working on the definition of the
solution
so hold on hold on roz i want to paint
the picture you have here three
you have two coders and a ceo out of the
garage bootstrap just raised your series
your series a and you're knocking on the
door of mastercard and you're saying hey
we have this
we have this technology is this relevant
and they're saying yes it's very
relevant
right actually that meeting is a funny
story
um we arrived at the meeting after
meeting with a potential uh partner in
atlanta now we planned to have the the
flight in
the previous day to arrive to new york
to purchase uh but
it was snowed in and the airports were
closed the first time
that the snow hit atlanta for a decade
of course so we drove all
night uh in shifts until we arrived
at the meeting on time and the rest is
history
wow wow and and you okay so i mean that
literally is
like an entrepreneur movie right you get
in the car and driving all night okay so
so
do you begin i guess working with
mastercard and helping
so just you know dumb it down for me
what is ever complained and how do you
actually you know
help those that are doing online
transactions because
i'm very familiar with the the
complexity of compliance obviously i'm
coming also from the insurance space now
at hippo
so i understand complaints a little bit
but but not nearly enough to really
understand what you're doing
uh so our specialty is to find
connections between uh
activity online activities especially
around commerce
uh what we found is that today it's very
easy to set up an online merchant
uh almost too easy uh it takes about 10
minutes and access to your favorite uh
website builder
was building a platform and you have a
website where you go and you can start
transacting
and that um that's a um
acceleration of new versions popping up
has created a huge smoke screen where
you can hide illegal activity
uh without people and detecting it and
uh that's what we're doing in a level
compliant we map out all
of the online activity online commerce
security and we
uh by extracting data from each and
every website
about what the website is doing and
where the owners of the websites were
which is
who registered domain with the company
behind it in other details
we're able to connect these activities
together so in your approach
our customers little banks uh paying
service providers anyone who works with
our merchants
we can get their motion portfolio and
connect the legitimate merchants to
illegal activities
so you know give me a little bit of
background about this market because it
sounds like this
is a problem that is especially relevant
today maybe
less so 15 or 20 years ago when it
wasn't when building
you know online presence and gaining
credibility
wasn't as democratized as it is today
why aren't there so many others working
in the space or maybe there are i mean
because it sounds like this is one of
the most relevant things in today's age
especially as
practically all of our shopping is done
online and covet is just accelerating
e-commerce i'm sure like crazy
um so there are competitors in that area
um
i have the utmost respect for them and
we love a good competition
um and uh when we uh when we approached
the market we saw
a while ago uh we saw that uh that
problem was ramping up
uh uh sorry so really i see uh the
numbers of merchants rising up year
after year
yeah and there was no solution in sight
and then then we basically built
our our platform and uh uh yeah as the
area grew
uh our uh our market grew and the
company knew as well
so how do you then as one of the
founders and
and you know as vprd or and soon we'll
talk about the transition to product
how do you think or how much weight do
you give to the congestion of the space
and how your other competitors are
are approaching this because you know
and if if there are other competitors
that are direct competitors
i'm guessing right now look as you're in
the hyper growth stage and you're trying
to you know bring credibility in market
share
what are some of the key considerations
that you're bringing to the table
so um as an israeli company we started
from technology
of course but our competitors actually
started from different business aspects
uh so either from business analysts who
built
an online database and reflected its
customers
uh or different varieties of battery and
we
approached with a technology-based
solution really made things
uh much better for our customers um so
in that aspect we always try to maintain
that technological edge and think of the
next thing with the mark
where the market is going to uh so we
can stay ahead of the curve
and uh in better and that aspect when
you when you're building a company
building a startup you have to heavily
invest in r d all throughout your
lifecycle
and i'm sure hippo is still uh still
dedicating a lot of resources there
doubling down yeah yeah absolutely um
so uh it's something that's uh important
to uh to put a lot of emphasis on
especially when
there's always pressure to uh put more
in marketing and sales just to
bring the bottom line uh at higher
numbers uh but
at the end of the day you build up
technology you built an r d over the top
product
i love it okay so so you know again
going back
to three guys in the garage two coders
and a ceo you're approaching mastercard
and all of a sudden you have this huge
client
and this is after you know you're also
your main experience as a freelance
engineer is to help you know small teams
bring their products to fruition what
how
is this transition of going from you
know some israeli customers forever
compliant all of a sudden
seeing mastercard and working with one
of the one of the most
you know one of the biggest online
companies and give me a little bit of
taste as to
how what that's like so when you're
working with mastercard you have a lot
of
uh they presented the market basically
they uh correct they
sent us over to different uh different
global companies
that and uh we tested our product uh
in real time with them and they saw the
benefits and they become became
our first global customers and that
process
is really um it brings the company to a
different level of maturity because
when you look for a product everything
is very nice very clean
uh the valve proposition is very crisp
and that's what we're working on but
uh once you bring on enterprise
customers and we start from the largest
enterprise uh there are
a ton of other operational compliance
legal demands
to meet very long procurement processes
things that the company has to adjust to
and um
so we had someone in the bank so we were
all were able to ram that up but um
something that you have to take into
account when you start a b2b or v2
enterprise
were there any things that were
completely you know mind-blowing or very
surprising in this process as you're
maturing the company
very quickly because i'm guessing from
the moment that you're you know you're
signing with mastercard
pretty much it's like go time you have
to you have to
reach that maturity very quickly right
um yeah it's it's been a
it's been a meeting after meeting of
long requirements uh showing up on our
doorstep
uh and uh we had to ramp up the lmg team
very very quickly we had to wrap up
legal compliance
uh we had standardization efforts and uh
it's all a big as you again as you're
building your technology because uh
we're still a young company
um uh it's it's it's a huge uh take
to uh it's huge a task to take of course
and so
talk to me a little bit about this
transition that you're doing now so vp
rnd forever compliant
you're you started as a founder in vpr
and you continued until now and you
mentioned that you're making this
very interesting transition to running
the product
yeah so that was it all started about
two years ago
um i thought that so as a young founder
you're doing pretty much
a little bit of everything right so um
i thought that there was a place for me
to uh to really take the
product from the company forward and to
uh to really lead that area
and uh it's also been very interesting
for me personally and uh
and it seemed like something that the
company would benefit from
so then we started looking for the
guarantee took us about a year to find
someone who's suitable and was
a great hiring still uh obviously with
the company uh
and last year last august actually i
started to run the product
uh i have to say that being a technology
lead and
founder and product is uh they have a
lot of overlap
between them uh especially in the young
company because you always when you're
building technology you always have to
uh to have a product mindset you have to
understand what's replicable and what's
not
uh what to build what not to build when
to say no uh and it's difficult with
enterprise customers
uh but it's something that you have to
always take into account and really take
that and to ramp up uh
first of all myself and product because
i haven't had any part formal training
before
i ram that up and change that mindset
it's been amazing for me
but how do you go to an existing company
that you're a part of
and all of a sudden assume the role of
running the product without
prior knowledge of running products for
companies because
essentially you're taking on the
responsibility of now building something
that needs to scale needs to service the
market and
i'm guessing that one of the main
motivations now of every complaint is to
start getting
gaining market share and gaining market
dominance and
a lot of it is on your shoulders now
because you're running the product
so how do you how do you quickly catch
up to those to that skill set
uh so for me it's been a few parts uh
first of all
um i'm i'm fortunate to know a lot of
very uh very talented people
uh uh who are their top product managers
and uh
i met with them learned from them and
asked a lot of questions
nagged them for uh for a while and a lot
that way and i've also had a chance to
work alongside uh
product managers amazing product
measures uh
and last but not least i've also
dedicated a lot of time to read almost
any book in existence our product
um to really formalize the training and
to uh to
wrap up my knowledge around that um and
i'm still learning a lot
every day um so it's never a it's a
never-ending
story i'm sure i'm sure
what are the biggest challenges that you
and your co-founders have faced
over the past few years in your ever
complaint journey
it could be you know the the
bootstrapping part the fundraising part
the hiring part what were some of the
things that you faced that
like wow like this is a huge challenge
and i'm really excited to tackle it
um so there are a lot of different
challenges over there i have to say
uh but i think the main uh uh the main
challenge we have is to
going from local to global so from uh
israel to the united states to
everywhere else in the world
and different geographies that have
different relationship with mindsets
at different procurement policies uh and
to learn to take all that in and to
really uh
build a company around this process it's
been an amazing
amazing journey and i love it
and any advice that you would give to
other young entrepreneurs who are
perhaps just starting their journey
maybe they're finishing you know the
same course that
that you and i did and now they're
transitioning out to the world and
they're considering
starting out a company from their garage
but as as you both of us know it's
it's it's in it's a weird experience
going out from from the idf's
you know bubble to not the real to the
real world and
doing different technology obviously uh
so first of all i'll say i
i'll say what i always say to my
employees when they ask if
one day they want to open the startup
whether it's do it or not i will say do
it and if you do that i will help you
anywhere anywhere i can
uh i think it's an amazing experience so
anybody watching this
if anybody needs advice raza brahmov uh
where's the problem is here
absolutely my my door and facebook are
always open
um and so okay so so now
comes the most important question why
did you do it so i understand why
you transitioned from freelance and you
said okay i'm helping others achieve
their their dreams
what i'm trying to understand also is
why you chose to go in
and start a company because you didn't
choose to go and work at a corporate
or experience you know running
engineering at other companies and then
product
you said i'm ready to go and start my
own my own business and that's an
interesting transition to me so
talking a little bit about why i chose
to do it and what really gets you up
every morning
um so actually it was a decision i made
when i was very young i was about
17 i think i saw the great stories of
the startups of the day
and i i wanted i wanted my own story i
had to be written
um so so that was that's my main drive
right here and uh
i'm still my main driver to date uh so i
want to write that story i want to write
a big story that people
uh that young people will look up to and
say i want to be that person one day
and how do you how do you do that then
so does that mean that
ever compliant needs to you know reach
substantial heights
does it mean that you need to to to
to be seen as somebody who who's sort of
like a mentor to others how do you get
to the point where you're writing
that story um so
first of all there's no iron company uh
so ever compliant uh
um is like it's like a baby for me it's
uh i've seen it from uh from infancy and
i i want to see it which is as high as
possible
and um and as long as as long as they're
birthing me i will always uh strive to
to move that company forward
um and um
yeah i think that's it that's i love it
roz i want to thank you again for your
generosity and your time and
it it sounds like an incredible journey
i'm still waiting for the i'm
going to wait for the movie about the
meeting with mastercard and driving all
night but
i need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
whatever it takes whatever it takes
i love it thank you very very much and
and i look forward to sharing this with
the world thank you
you